Now, I am beginning my journey here for a simple reason.
Since taking office, I have worked to renew American leadership...
...and pursue a new era of engagement with the world based on mutual interests and mutual respect.
And our efforts in the Asia Pacific will be rooted in no small measure...
...through an enduring and revitalized alliance between the United States and Japan.
From my very first days in office,...
...we have worked to strengthen the ties that bind our nations.
The first foreign leader that I welcomed to the White House was the Prime Minister of Japan.
And for the first time in nearly fifty years, the first foreign trip...
...by an American Secretary of State, Hillary Clinton, was to Asia, starting in Japan.
In two months, our alliance will mark its 50th anniversary.
A day when President Dwight Eisenhower stood next to Japan's Prime Minister...
...and said that, our two nations were creating an indestructible partnership...
...based on equality and mutual understanding.
In the half century since,...
...that alliance has endured as a foundation for our security and prosperity.
It has helped us become the world's two largest economies,...
...with Japan emerging as America's second-largest trading partner outside of North America.
It has evolved as Japan has played a larger role on the world stage...
...and made important contributions to stability around the world.
From reconstruction in Iraq, to combating piracy off the Horn of Africa,...
...to assistance for the people of Afghanistan and Pakistan,...
...most recently through its remarkable leadership in providing additional commitments...
...to international development efforts there.
Above all, our alliance has endured because it reflects our common values.
A belief in the democratic right of free people to choose their own leaders and realize their own dreams.
A belief that made possible the election of both Prime Minister Hatoyama and myself on the promise of change.
And together, we are committed to providing a new generation of leadership...
...for our people, and our alliance.
That is why, at this critical moment in history,...
...the two of us have not only reaffirmed our alliance, we have agreed to deepen it.
We have agreed to move expeditiously through a joint working group...
...to implement the agreement that our two governments reached on restructuring US forces in Okinawa.
And as our alliance evolves and adapts for the future,...
...we will always strive to uphold the spirit that President Eisenhower described long ago.
A partnership of equality and mutual respect.